good morning John were now a couple of
weeks into your paternity leave and
things going excellently correctly if
you want to keep making more babies and
I just collab with all the best
youtubers probably be okay by me miss
you though but it's been super fun also
grace went over four minutes the rule
though is unclear as to whether it's
videos on the vlogbrothers channel that
can't be over the four minutes or if
it's videos made by the vlogbrothers
that can't be over four minutes I'm
still not sure but grace found out and
she sent me this punishment served so
many other things happening in our fight
area right now John since you're busy
taking a break as an update here's
what's going on according to the people
at weird games the evil baby orphanage
card game has now sold over four
thousand copies it is also become a
mainstay of my partying gaming
activities right mix of luck and skill
and it's like three to seven players so
that it's 3 plus players apparently you
can play with infinite players your
craft area our minecraft server has seen
over 43,000 unique players 9700 diamonds
have been discovered and 3,500 mobs are
killed every single day it's a beautiful
and lovely place John kind of without
your knowledge I decided to do an
entertaining sex ed show called
sexplanations with these nice people
Lindsay what a sexplanations an
entertaining sex education channel on
YouTube that's just what I said
I know the brain scoop is going well
how's the brain scoop going the best
we're going to partner with the Chicago
Field Museum tell people about the
Chicago Field Museum Chicago Field
Museum is one of the largest and most
diverse collections in the world 25
million artifacts in their collection
how many do you have here 24,000 so
that's a lot of extra zeros for you it's
basically everything I could have ever
hoped for that I never even knew that I
wanted you will have his paperwork
filled out and he can come along with as
a temporary loan to the Field Museum
he's gonna stay shotgun crash chris has
been a lot of fun lately I am working my
butt off right now trying to solve the
problem of advertising valuing
distraction the same as or even more
than it values engagement but that's
taking some time sorry I'm working on
some new songs wad rather sweet foot
of excrement or eat a dozen tires or
maybe only ever read wet cat food for
the whole rest of my life Oh Jake ever
thing what are you do with your time
give it all your money to charity and I
get that so just fine but I'm what have
you got I got more jobs Minh maybe out a
no-good drunk laptop do it for the HPA I
don't care just do it today he's going
well dftba
here's shirts you ever been on
vlogbrothers day my dog has been in
videos with the cone of shame there's
Matthew isn't the worst shot ever we're
getting more shelves more shelves we're
expanding we have too many shirts no you
never have too many getters just enough
shirts we just started working with a
Harry Potter Alliance so we have a ton
of Harry Potter Alliance stuff for sale
open affecting up all the tibias
audiobooks most of them have already
been shipped out you should be getting
them any day now Stefan I've built a
computer specifically for use as a
hankgames machine I want to play more PC
games and the return of Hank and
Katherine plays Super Mario Brothers Wii
is today and finally of course the
nerdfighteria census was fascinating so
fascinating in fact that it took me 23
minutes to go through an overview of the
data I did that on Hanks channel there's
a link in the doobly-doo probably the
most fascinating statistic is that a
hundred and thirty thousand people
filled it out and a hundred percent of
the people that started filling it out
finished so thank you all for that one
of the things we learn from the survey
is that ninety seven thousand of you
would be interested in an email
newsletter from me and/or John which is
a lot of people interested in that so we
are setting that up and you can go to
Hank and John calm and sign up for that
it is and I don't want to brag here
probably the most beautiful website that
you will ever go to in your entire life
so you have to check it out it is just
freaking gorgeous and John I will not
see you Who am I gonna see on Tuesday
Hannah Hart I will see you on Tuesday i
am lindsay doe
I'm a clinical sexologist bachelor's in
psychology masters in Health and Human
Performance with a concentration in
health promotion